recently I got to sit down with dr. John
discuss acting and how he prepares for a
role let's take a look now let's talk
about your first film this year Rango
how did you prepare for an animated role
like that well when I first read the
screenplay for Rango a half way through
the script that realized I'm living a
lizard
and from there the character just sort
of evolved yeah you've done children's
films before let's talk about Charlie in
the Chocolate Factory how did you take
an iconic role like Willy Wonka and turn
it into your own well when I read the
screenplay for Charlie Java the battery
a half way through the script they're
realized I'm nothing charlie and from
there the character just sort of love
yeah how do you get into other
historical figures
what's your preparation for that you
want an example sure not one but when I
first read the screenplay for Oh 300 a
half way through the script I realized
I'm reading the wrong script and from
there the character just sort of the
ball yeah my hands on fire right now by
the way now how would you use that
character well the first time my hand
oh I've learned that when you act just
say lines then put it in a movie The
Nightmare on Elm Street I thought to
myself how could I use sense memory to
get the real feeling of being sucked
into a bed so I thought of a childbirth
in Reverse you know the baby crawling in
set out What's Eating Gilbert Grape
yes me I a section on the only word
Gilbert was eating the whole time what
is your favorite color
Oh
what and if you were going to be on a
desert island with any of the characters
that you play
sweet sweet hot yeah it's the most
trustworthy one it gets hairy literally
you know right you think you won't be
groomed what is your favorite curse word
oh yeah I'd have to say dick Oh dick
yeah
it just sums up everything penises
everything right occasionally which is
yeah that means that about become Jewish
what advice could you give to aspiring
actors well when you first get the
script about halfway through the script
you're gonna realize which character
you're playing thank you so much for
your time no sandwich
oh dear today I once thought about
becoming Jewish right right yeah weirdo
thank you so much for the time John we
really appreciate it